es una derrota porque es tres de los
principales partidos que apoyaban al
actual gobierno pues boicotearon este
botón no votaron la confianza al
gobierno al cual hasta hoy pertenecían y
esto sin duda marca el final del
gobierno de amplia coalición al gobierno
de unión nacional que mantenía en pie el
ejecutivo dirigido por mario draghi aquí
en italia esta mañana en su discurso
ante el senado italiano draghi hizo un
llamado a las diferentes fuerzas
políticas del país para reconstruir un
pacto de gobierno los invito a reiterar
un apoyo sin fallas al actual ejecutivo
pero durante el día pues estos tres
partidos en sustancialmente respondieron
negativamente el movimiento cinco
estrellas antisistema la liga el
movimiento el partido ultraderechista de
matteo salvini y forza italia de
centroderecha de silvio de luz con estas
tres fuerzas políticas entonces
retiraron en este día su apoyo al
gobierno y frente a esta situación se
espera que en un futuro cercano mario
draghi
y su dimisión al presidente italiano
sergio material y ahora natalia que
escenarios hay posibles en la política
italiana
pues a partir del momento en que mario
draghi presente oficialmente su dimisión
al presidente italiano sergio mataré la
es este último sergio matar el a quien
se vuelve pues el árbitro de la
situación él puede decidir si nombrar un
nuevo primer ministro encargado de
tratar de formar un nuevo gobierno pero
puede también decidir si quiere disolver
el parlamento para para convocar
elecciones anticipadas en este caso pues
el gobierno de mario draghi quedaría
todavía a cargo manejando la
administración los asuntos corrientes
mientras se organizan estos nuevos
comicios que podrían ser a finales de
septiembre oa inicios del próximo mes de
octubre
[Música]